OK 我录屏录不了
我就直接录声音了
我看着手机上的这个十个卡片
OK 卡一是一个非常高波动ATR的股票
然后的话是它出现了新高
回踩21EMA均线进行了一个undercut
对吧
那我们看到的是价格重新回到了上方
而当天的离21EMA的ATR0.69
那说明这个
它的可能继续突破
继续盘整
或者是往上的可能性是很大的
这只是中间的一个休息
我会在这边买
然后以21均线作为止损入场
这是卡片一号
那我们看卡片二号
是一个ATR只有3.5%的每一个股票
它一直在21均线上进行一个很窄的盘整
然后这是从21和50均线第一次交叉之后
第一次回踩21均线
21也没均线
所以卡二我肯定会买
我相信它接下来是能够去新高的
这是卡二
卡三
OK
卡三比较简单
卡三的话
它在21EMA下直接
直接这个突破了
就向下突破了
所以说21EMA是一个失败的支撑
那接下来很有可能是去回踩50均线
所以卡三是绝对不买
卡四
卡四的话
它是我们看到高点是在25天之前
然后它是个很相对低波动的股票
那我觉得现在可能还是处于一个
在第一位开始慢慢盘整
因为我们看到前几天是被21EMA给压制的
然后最近它又重新回到了21EMA之上
对吧
那很有可能是进行一个盘整的阶段
所以卡四的话
就看吧
这个股票不是我的风格
因为它的太温和了
对
卡四的话我选择看
卡五
OK
又来一个高波动的6.4的ATR
然后它离高点非常的近
离高点非常近
然后它在21EMA进行了一个
假摔的一个动作
进行了一个Undercut rally
那很有可能
我是要买的
我看一下
然后它特别又出现了这个
涨幅超过4%的这么个
这么一天
所以卡五肯定我会买
对
嗯
卡五我会买
因为它离前高很近
但是等等
卡五的话
要两个R
涨12%
那这个我就有点
不确定
它能不能涨到两个R
对
那卡五的话就是看
嗯
卡五我不会买
卡五我
我会想等它再接近
21EMA的时候
我会去买它
Yeah
Sorry
可能卡五现在
我觉得它会涨
但是我不知道它能不能涨那么多
嗯
卡六
卡六ATR是3.7%
那就还算温顺
呃
我们看到也是一个
第一次回踩21
呃
EMA的一个结构
然后它离高点的话
只有4.3%
也就说一个ATR
那我觉得是有可能能够继续冲新高的
这是第一
这是回踩之后的第一次
出新高之后的第一次回踩21EMA
我觉得通常会是买好的买一点
卡六我会选择买
呃
卡七
耶
卡七的话也是一个不特别好
他首先他之前的高点在40天以前
啊
然后呢
他又跌破了21均线
50均线也说
说明跌破了
那他要进行更长的一个盘整
呃
我不觉得我会在
这个位置进行一个买盘
嗯
但是卡七出现了RS
新高
但是也没有4%的一个
you know
update
对吧
所以卡七还是比较看
看
不做决定
卡七
OK
卡八
呃
卡八的话
高点在7天之前
ATR6.3
离52周高的话
两个ATR
也就是说
这个问题是
这个股票在第一次
在出新高之后
第一次回踩21均线
然后能否重新在20天之内
重新回到高点
呃
有点难说
但是我倾向会买
我倾向会在
不对
他离他离21
也没有点有点远
对
如果是小于一个ATR的话
我会考虑
我会特别考虑去买
现在的话
我觉得他还缺了点条件
离这个ATR21
EMA有点远
嗯
卡八还是看
不做抉择
卡九
OK
你说20天之内
他能不能到前高
我觉得有可能
对
但是买的话
我不一定会买
出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出
出出出出出出出
出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出出